oh this is
amazing this is what we won yeah I know
I I should get this out like maybe today
even definitely Friday at this point
there's like some like automization [__]
it's like kind of [__]
but yes
so yeah I mean the pivots are very very
clean on here is that is that the 59 22
that
P you see that's that's where I get out
of my long yeah only because espx was
showing maximum gamma there and that's
it yeah exactly I mean
that's I think yeah it's really great
pivots um I've already said this but
like you know I try not to think
directionally I just think like okay
well I don't I want to interact with
spot price unless I'm at a pivot and
then I'm you know then I sus out where
do I want to go or where I want to leave
really in this case right on
22 I guess we do have a Target here at
87 possibly yeah possibly yeah look at
that it's just just a
two yeah I shifting down
so and and and if you I mean obviously I
don't if you if you look at this but
that uh 58
8786 is been level for you know couple
of days Market it's just oh yeah bounce
come back bounce come back bounce so
it's an important
level
um that's that's basically where I go
kind of today
because onx that's where those uh puts
came in on Monday actually yeah exactly
yeah that's that's amazing isn't it like
I don't know what moves the more I don't
know if the option guys they going into
the charts and they say okay let's going
to do this here or what but you know
it's amazing how these levels kind of
tend to work just just just just levels
I don't
know yeah I mean you know typically I
think they're just hedging some other
exposure but like that still has a clear
effect on on the system right and yeah
whether or not they're
using I don't think they're using TA or
anything like that but you know the
effect is like all the small fish are
kind of following in their
wake iing yes and when this tool is is
kind of going to be available for for
the
users oh this
uh maybe today maybe Friday oh um I'm
just working on the well it's it's it's
kind of ready already actually there
there's some there's a few quality of
life tweaks I want to add to this um and
then I should be able to get out by like
either probably by this Friday in like
two days amazing that's good but there's
like this because I know that like I've
I've been like a kind of a stickler
about this like I I like the latter view
just because I care about what happens
what's happening right now but I I also
realized there's clearly a lot of I mean
obviously people are used to their time
series charts um and there's a lot of
value in like seeing the prior pivots oh
yeah and so like you know there there's
this one I want to add there's also some
other stuff for
um like I want to add uh Max long gamma
Max short gamma oh okay yeah so the cyan
and purple bars going to bring those and
then we can chart those along studies
and you know a lot do yeah great J I
know it's been almost an hour but um one
of the questions I have for you is
um and that's the question the guys here
in sou in Colombia they they asked me
too they say like can can can you ask J
to
actually um explain how to trade
basically how you trade oh yeah uh the
the NQ using gamma and and I know in the
in the in the in the chat in this score
you put some rules um for reversion
trades and continuation trades and and
and you may and and you mention also
that you know like easy you call them
like kind of easy trayes
and yeah yeah I mean
yeah well I I call them easy trades in
the sense of like they're the easier
trades right so if you think about
there's you know you can trade however
you want but there's always like there's
the hard trade because you can't let go
of your bias and then there's easier
trade if you learn to just kind of let
go you know that's what I mean by easy
right I don't want to say like this is
actually easy because not I know I know
yeah but but it would be nice like if
you can give us some example of what it
would be like a reversion trade um
oration trade in in in this context
I don't know
how how do I even like there's a very
classic
one
um you know partly I used to have this
rule where um certain reversion trades
are ideal like EOD or like the afternoon
but I think that doesn't even matter
like at all um okay so but to get more
concrete um
so there there's sort of two things that
I look at um to make this as simple as
possible like I think you can or for me
I've been getting away with only looking
at the long short gamma lad um and then
since we've had regime bot um I don't
need to pull up the net convexity chart
although I always have that in mind um
but it's it's it's two things it's it's
regime and then it's just these
levels um Now by regime I just
mean there's like two ways of looking at
it one is net convexity right so like if
net convexity is very high that means in
general participants are very long V
long volatility which means that you
know the mark they're expecting the
market to be hot um but you know more
more simply it's literally just watching
the the tape um and by tape I don't even
mean time in sales I mean like like a
tick chart like it doesn't even matter
well preferably not a time uh delimited
chart like a tick chart I think is
better for uh tape reading
granularity uh but I'm just looking to
see if like literally is the price
action hot or cold if it's really hot
meaning
that you know not only
um is it very active but there's you
know it's very clear sometimes it's very
clear when there's someone pushing um
someone actually present on the tape and
it's not just like hft alos that are
scalping stuff right um so there needs
to be tldr there needs to be some degree
of of heat to the tape um then it's
quite literally especially with NQ it's
quite literally a classic one is coming
into some level uh fast for a lack of a
better word well High volatility is
really I guess the technical word um and
just literally just bidding the
level and looking for a bounce off of it
um or looking for and and again this is
like
non
directional um well here's actually a
classic
one this didn't really require that hot
of a tape um but like this is a classic
example of okay it's very unlikely we're
going to move we're going to get through
um this area um and so I'm looking for
some sort of reversion usually I'm not
just so I have a level that's being
defined in terms of like entry I still
use very classic like I'm looking for
some sort of impulse high and by impulse
I mean like you know it's it's those
Wicks that occur where someone gets
caught um or there's like just this
really
localized um liquidity seeking Behavior
where the tape will like come up and tap
something and it'll catch it and then
it'll it'll melt or it'll shoot up right
okay um
and you know I'm looking for stuff like
that and I'm leading on on this now one
thing to keep in mind when you're trying
to play these reversions right is that
like uh you know the participants who
are opening these positions they have a
much
greater I want to say like tolerance for
how far the tape move typically you can
get away with very tight stops I me like
even on NQ I know the common outage is
that like oh if it's less liquid your
stops should be WI
but I find that to be completely false
or like if the tape is hotter you should
widen your stops like that is that's
actually dangerously wrong I find that
like the hotter the tape you can get
very tight with Stomps um if you can't
get closer than like like 20 points is
is a lot already you you should be able
to aim for like 10 to 15 and if you if
you can't if you're getting stopped out
on those kinds of entries it's because
your entry is not proper uh and it's not
really due to like the volatility of of
the tape right but in general with these
levels you know I'm looking you can get
very very tight um with that kind of
stuff and it's it's it's basically just
okay well there's a reversion occurring
here we just CAU capped right here maybe
stop is right here at this short gamma
node you know or somewhere in this
vicinity right so like at most like what
this is about 700
maybe I hide behind my stop behind this
long gamma node this little one right
here there's you see the lifted put no
um that's like a what 15o
stop yeah more likely like we don't even
get over this right um like you get very
and if it's if it's beyond this right if
it's beyond a 15-point stop like just
let it go you know like you don't have
to then maybe look for a long bid off
this level and go the other way um and
then after that you know and I think
this is also one
that I think is just as important like
managing the trade right like I'm just
looking for the next cluster of long
gamma nodes okay that that that's
basically an example of a reversion
trade right and yeah I think you put
that put like I quote offer a level for
reversion that you want a long C gamma
to bounce off and go down so that's
basically what we just saw long gamma
the price kind of found resistance and
then came down that's that's a good
example yeah today is particularly
excellent for this actually but let me
ask you something if if the spot price
actually you know move above those those
resistance level that that would be kind
of continuation trade right so so
actually that long gamma is is actually
pushing the price higher and and you
would and you would go long right yes so
there's two things right so like you
know always thinking in terms of spot
wants to move away from these So like um
so that's
like you know SP wants to move away from
these levels but I think also on a
practical aspect is you don't
necessarily like yes you can look for
the Longs over it um but I think at
least for me personally from an
execution standpoint you know I prefer
to
um how do I say this so like everyone
has a bias right yeah whether your bias
aligns with Like the quote unquote ease
whether your bias aligns with like the
actual Market regime determines whether
your trades are going to be easy or hard
um for me I find it very difficult to
let go of my
bias um I I don't know if that's true
for everyone
my bias is to go long I find it very
hard to I'm kind of I'm like kind of a
per Bearer lately I I don't know why but
um I I think you know there's this
thinking that you can
change at least I've it seems that
people think that they can try if they
align their bias with what the market is
actually doing then their trades will
suddenly uh succeed but for
me quite a bit of ref reflecting I find
that like I it's not quite feasible it's
very difficult for me to do that so
it's strangely it's easier for me to
like okay if if my bias is not allotting
with the market um it's better to just
step away because I don't want to take
the hard trades right so like yes if I'm
short
here and because I'm bearish but Mark
regime is is bullish
it still makes sense to try to take what
would be qu hard trade at that point but
if it exceeds this area I just speaking
practical terms I prefer to not try to
play for the long continuation you know
because just because my bias now I know
it's not aligning with like the actual
Market regime that turns into the hard
trade for me personally um even though
technically that would be you know so
there's there's a bit of um like
self-reflection I think that comes into
classing stuff as yeah as as easy or
hard right but the point is that like
the point is picking the area that you
want to interact right that you want to
change your exposure right it's okay to
be wrong it's okay for your bias to be
wrong as long as you're willing to just
restrict your interactions with spot
price to these specific areas um you can
minimize like well you minimize loss
right you can minimize the risk because
you're not trying to enter here or enter
here you know where like spot price is
gonna ra probably range quite a bit
before going to the next node or
whatever um it's much harder to find
risk right so then that's where people
get I think can get chopped up quite a
bit um it's not so much like if people
really did follow the rules of only
interacting at specific levels like you
can have a pretty awful win rate and
You' be fine right but it's just the
about restricting when you really want
to interact actually another meta aspect
of that is that like especially with
this um I find it best to not even like
actively trade unless I see a lot of
long gamma you know because it takes a
lot for people to be willing to transact
like this um and so like you know if I
don't see a lot of long gamma then it's
probably not like the tape is probably
not worth trading I me today is
definitely
for
trading I
see because you know if if you put the
time a little bit um it's quite
interesting that the price you know went
up to that kind of resistance let's put
it that name so everyone can understand
and where we actually you were
explaining then it went down right to
look that that was a good resistance
that was a good show I mean a good trade
to you know to to to be short in the
market and then the price got down to
the
2610 and person a person like me would
think oh I I gonna buy and put my stop
loss just below and then yeah if it
doesn't work I will sell it I mean if
the if the spot crosses that support I
will set
it and yeah so in my how I how I view
this sort of is okay we come to midday
this position gets is pretty large
positioning gets put on and then like
I'm pretty short biased I would have Tak
that short I have a clear
targets um but like and of course I
think this is kind of where the
discretion maybe comes in okay um but
for me it's like okay I have this target
right but like you get out of it it's
it's still well there you have like
multiple options right you always have
the option of reduce exposure
um flatten or
reverse
and I think this depends on like Market
regime right whether you only want to
flatten or like which one you want to do
right so like classically when people
talking about like range days you would
just flatten here and you would bid for
reverse to come back up um if you're
like me I'm like okay well I'd rather
just trim and I want my Runner right so
I start looking
you know for further stuff okay um but
that's I think there's no hard set rule
um with respect to that right well you
know that's that's that's that's quite
interesting the way you see it because
uh you know the the gamma above is quite
large you know compared to the gamma
below and and you know that's that's
that's I mean for me I didn't I didn't I
didn't think about it and uh I I could
have say some some stop losses there
saying like oh look this is not as big
as the one above so probably probably is
not going to work as a support compared
to the one above who works as
a well so here I'll share this with you
this is like call and put gex but so
this is where that short positioning
came on was around 700 quite literally
top tick and like yes like we come down
to like 600s five I mean we got all way
to 590s right and then yes you do have
like a pretty large R version right you
have like a 50 60 point reversion so
like yes you can take those reversion
trades right it is effective I mean of
course like this this gets into you know
how do you want to
manage
um when you're trying to optimize like
your your your your expected value you
know it's sort of of okay well is it
likely
for because if you look at the past
couple of days right and you even look
at it this morning like the the impetus
really would be to like okay I'll just
flip long and then look for the runner
continuation um and you kind of do get
that effect and then it's about like
okay well you know how much do you want
to like extend your p&l I think there's
an extent to which it's an knowable
thing right um like whether you want to
be open to the right tail of or the left
tail in this case of like full short
continuation but I think it's very
difficult to hold you know if you're
short here that's very like pretty much
impossible really I think uh humanly to
hold a short through this especially
because we had the long gamma pivot here
and it's it was Major put gamma as well
right although there are shifts you know
lower
um but I think that's that's a hard
that's hard to have like a rule of thumb
I think it's it's really personal
actually you know I know that um Clark
he you know he loves moving his stops
into profit and he doesn't care at least
lately he doesn't care to look for like
these extreme uh Runners I prefer to not
move my stops and like let the runner
just you know God willing go wherever it
goes you know but that also doesn't work
out right and I think if you're
susceptible to
tilting um that can also be a really bad
idea to let the runner
run yeah yeah but that you know what
that's that's an amazing Insight because
um as I said before to you I I didn't
know how to trade inq by looking at at
that kind of a gamma profile I I was
trading inq by SP spy so and looking for
those kind of uh maximum levels of
positive or negative gamma but you know
by you sharing this you know making it
clear now it's just just so much clear
because I saw I saw the chart I saw in
Discord like all the guys were trading
putting stops making money I was like
how the hell they do it I don't know how
how how they read this and and now it
makes a lot of sense and it does make
sense I spent a very long time in in es
you know like that's
where it was it's funny so it was like
middle of
2023 last year yeah when like shortville
really came like it was it was awful in
terms of um the price action you that
that's kind of what got me to transition
into into NQ um I think ESL is a lot
better now like the PA seems a lot less
muddy um but really it was just about
learning during a time of like very
suppressed uh V and what I what I find
is that like like yes enq is
Wilder um because it's it's less liquid
because it's it's not really it's a
really inefficient instrument um you
know the options are very inefficient
like that's why we can even see these
these pivots so clearly is because like
they're just so expensive and there's
just way way more liquid instruments you
can use to um make plays off of the ndx
or NQ value right and so when they do
make these plays it makes it very much
more apparent it's much more clear where
the levels are um just as in like NQ if
you're looking at like I think the tape
is easier to read there because like it
is um less liquid and so like when
someone gets caught like it's very very
clear versus es like you know it's quite
a bit more efficient
um yeah and you know what that that
makes sense because um because you go NQ
and and when you start kind of in this
trading thing people tell you oh triple
Q is better and you should look triple Q
because it's more liquid that NQ but
what you mention is totally right you
know in enq is I think it's the
institutionalsales
retail is am I right or yeah yeah it's
also true from like if when you're
trying to like classify like um
orderflow you know like es if you're
measuring time in sales it's a it's just
harder to or even I yes yeah spy as well
um because there's so much more going on
so many more positions especially with
like differing incentives right um it
muddies up like the view of it quite a
bit more
yeah just I I got a question for you I'm
probably I'm going to take more of your
time because it's been it's been almost
an hour and a half but um looking
looking on the spot price here and then
when I go into my trading platform it's
a little bit of discrepancy right it's
kind of 10 points
discrepancy yeah is it is it I mean is
you know because my system is wrong no
no no okay so yes this really good
question I I will refer people to this
video when people ask um
so the
okay practically speaking the first
thing to check is just the clock right
so if the if the clock is it should be
within a few seconds if not one second
um if if you're like your futures broker
should have an accurate time clock to
tell you what the latest time time is so
as long that's aligned you are seeing
the
current uh price now to clarify why
that's the case um so this is not truly
Futures spot and uh options this is the
ndx options and spot price but okay what
we do is we calculate the premium
because there's a premium between ndx
and NQ uhuh um it's some amount that VAR
do like carry costs and a bunch of like
term structure stuff not important but
you know we calculate that pre-market
and then we add it to our ndx levels to
then translate them into
NQ now that premium can vary on an
intraday
basis um such that okay maybe we
translate the
levels to
um uh you know plus five but then on an
intraday basis that premium is actually
ranging from a plus three or plus seven
or plus 10 right so that's what makes it
look like it's
fluctuating um but what helps I think is
that it's not actually changing um like
in this case right we're looking at
693 and maybe the premium was different
at this time at like around 12:00 maybe
it was like plus 10 or plus 15 or
something uh but the spot price relative
to that level is still the same like
it's still Yes um that is still the
level to that we care about um I don't
know if that answer your question yeah
but um it really is to because I mean
from what we seen today is the know
trading um um andq using the gamma
basically we need to be very quick you
know we we we we really need to be
quicker to to actually put the put put
the put the entry and put the stop loss
so what I to be honest what I um and
probably you can help me with this I
found difficult is like because I
usually have like 10 points like you
know it's nothing but it's it's like a
little bit different I I don't know when
to actually put my trade in in my
platform because you know probably that
where you have you know that resistance
there six you know 600 on one
620 but but I don't know if it's I
should refer to my trading platform and
wait to the price to go there or I
should just hit the platform as soon as
I see guest boot getting there what do
you
think um so there's two solutions one is
I think
the a little more friction well there's
also a third one that's on R end um so
one solution I do is I check I literally
just like okay you know currently our
premium is varying like by plus five so
if I'm looking at this level then I just
I I know this is sounds awful I just add
the premium in my head so I'm like okay
503 I shift it 508 that's my target okay
um the other one is okay I'm you know
maybe I'm
like maybe I'm in a position or I'm
coming into this position um like okay
say these calls just came in right like
we're right here I got long in this
thing and like you know off this level
or this area whatever then they come in
um I know that like that this time stamp
is now you know or whatever the current
now is and I know that like okay well
this is literally at you know wherever
spot price is and so uh you know I just
I translate in my head I guess because
like this is where spot price is and I
know that NQ corresponds relative to
those levels in the same amount so I
know that okay maybe 10 or 15 or 20
points ahead is like the top end of this
this area right um that's another
solution or if I'm looking here I'm just
keeping this in mind and I'm looking at
where this is on like volume profile or
something and then I'm like I'm trying
to adjust it while I'm you know managing
this position uh another solution you
know on our end we do plan on getting
actual Futures data and with that
will'll come we've been looking at this
vendor called datab Bento um well we're
going to add actual Futures volume we'll
get futures options we're going to
aggregate that with the index options
and then we can have like a true like an
actual Futures data spot price so be
directly corresponding instead of this
premium translated like pseudo you know
future spot price no but you know what
that that helps a lot that because
that's something that I was like kind of
puzzled my mind oh well should I enter
as soon as I see the level and and but
it makes a lot of sense now because
usually it's not that much it's like
Five Points six points or something like
that it's not that big difference um but
yeah yeah it makes a lot of sense
um and I was going to say you know like
basically you you you show us how to
basically you trade and and and and as I
say to the guys here you know when NQ I
agree with you we have to put like very
tight stops if it doesn't work the level
does it Let It Go um you know not full
stop and you know tomorrow is another
day or later on you will have more
opportunities yeah but I think the way
you explain it is is fantastic and and
and I think that's how the guys in that
chat trade right in the state Futures
that's that's how they do it I think so
I mean Clark is a beast you know Clark
is very um well don't really want to get
into that here but um you know there
there's
like if you can manage to have a a sort
of ruthlessness towards your
execution um like I think that is ideal
you know like if you can TR if you
really
separate um your trade ideas from your
identity I think it goes a long way
towards you know because I know that
like obviously it's money right like
everyone has a particular relationship
with money that's just kind of our
nature and so you know when you're
having you know some sort of trade
thesis and it goes wrong of course of
course it's going to affect you on a
personal basis right and like it's it's
not like the the danger is not your
thesis being wrong it's it's your your
relationship with money okay maybe
that's a little bit too much for this
talk um but that's like you know I think
very valuable that's something for
psychology trading psychology yeah yeah
no it's and it's true it's just
basically the ego like you don't want to
be wrong but at the end of the day as as
a friend of mine told me listen it could
be the most ugly trade but if that make
you money just do it doesn't have to be
pretty it doesn't have to be pretty and
you don't have to feel like you you've
done it right oh you beat the market
forget about it just make your money and
get out get out of it yeah it's also
like you know the market doesn't really
give a [__] about what you think you
know the market is just going to do what
it wants to do oh yeah definitely
definitely it's you know it's at the end
of the day is you know thank you and
thank JN because this this tool has been
amazing and has helped so many Traders
Futures Traders especially honestly I I
know I can't imagine how much War you
guys have to do behind the scenes but
you know it's been fantastic and today
you know it's it's been amazing to know
how you guys trade
uh these NQ ndx and um and I'm sure I'm
going to start to use it tomorrow pretty
sure yeah I'm glad to hear that you know
like like it's sure it's a lot of work
but like it's also I mean most of the
stuff I like half the time I'm making it
for myself um because it just helps me
and I like I don't know it feels like a
privilege to be able to make it such
that you know you guys are also getting
value out of it so you know for me it's
not really we still work but it's not
it's not bad um but I'm glad to like
this you guys it is it is trust me it
use a lot of value to to actually trade
and you know I I've been quite good at
this I mean to be honest with you I for
me was quite difficult starting this
this trading because I was an
Institutional Trader in London and and
and just recently I read a book that say
like well the statistics shows that 5%
of Traders so actually got into this job
actually succeed but guess what in
traders who go into retail 1% and I oh
my god really and it's and it's all
about the ego and you
know you you got all you know you ego
and and and you got a stable salary and
etc etc but but you know that's what I'm
saying like for me personally using this
tool has been amazing and and I can't
thank you enough honestly thank you for
saying
J I don't know I don't know if you want
to add something I mean I mean we we
talk a lot about many things how you
trade all these volatility skew but it's
something that you think we should know
for for the Futures Traders or something
that probably we
miss part of it is like screen time
right part of it is like
um I think that like stuff like this it
can be very confusing due to the
terminology often used um but I I think
there is like an INT intuition that can
be built um that doesn't really
require um like it's not as complicated
as people make it obviously it's still
very difficult that's that's that's
that's the screen time like listen I I'm
helping some guys and and and you just I
just tell them it's just a screen time I
mean you you can you it's like it's like
flying an airplane you read a book in
three months you know all the
instructions but you actually have to go
on you know be a pilot and
flight many many many hours it's the
same with this thing
is yeah that's the reason I I decided to
you know ask you to to do this interview
because I don't know so many people get
into this and they have no idea it's
just like they see some lines and they K
their levels like technical levels and
and really it's a lot behind those you
know all seen today I I do want to say I
okay I made me think of something uh I
said this like a while ago where um I
think this very
common uh path for a lot of retail
Traders where you start off and like you
want to know everything about the market
and so you start putting all these
things onto um your charts like you're
trying to build this indicator that
indic at you're trying to give this
reasoning and you're like okay well now
how to combine these reasons um and then
you get to a certain point where you
start you know you've gotten more
experience and you start removing things
from your chart um you're cutting it
down right you're trying to simplify it
and eventually you you end up back with
just a
grayscale tick chart you know um
I think that you know obviously there's
so many different ways of of trading I I
don't think this is the end all be all I
but like for me at least like this is
this is pretty much the simplest that I
can think of in terms of okay I want to
look at options market and I just
combine that with Futures tape and then
I don't give a [__] about anything else
and like this is you know this has been
my my Nest I guess you could say a lot
of value to be gained from like don't
even don't even put a don't even put a
moving average right like just like turn
off all your colors all that crap right
don't even look at um you know don't
look at anything but just the little
kenle bars and like it's hard because
you get bored and you're like I don't
know what the [__] I'm looking at or
looking for right but like there's just
a tremendous amount of um I don't I
don't know if I want to say intuition I
guess it was it's intuition that can be
built um from just observing uh you know
the the local price action because I
don't know I it took me a long time but
I I think it's very clear um but it's
it's hard to see that if you have too
many things on your on your chart you
know yes and you you know I want to
share something with you and with the
with the you know the guys who are going
to watch this video and when when I was
in London working for Investment Bank we
we never had a a course in technical
analysis or trading No never they never
pay for that you know what they pay a
lot they pay for psych you know uh
psychology trading and all these kind of
things and really yeah the latest the
latest I mean before I came back to
Colombia I have this training with this
guy called stti Wars he's he used to
train the elite soldiers in the UK and
and and he he did all all these kind of
scientific research what's happening in
your brain and in your mind and when you
mention about intuition they found out
that actually that gut feeling is is all
the neurons in your body because you
don't have neurons only in your brain
you have it in your body and you have
millions of millions of neurons in your
body and they are learning without you
even knowing so when you spend a lot of
screen time that that that amazing
billions of neurons in your body at
learning and then when you see something
and you don't know what it is but you
got the god feeling the intuition yeah
it's actually that neurons that actually
learn so that's that's why screen time
is important yeah and that you know
that's something that that guy told me
at that time and I just I remember every
single day of my life and I say you know
what just it playes across like so many
things right like you know oftentimes
like in in in software people talk about
tutorial hell which is where people are
trying to learn how to code but they're
just they just keep watching tutorials
on YouTube but they don't like just
literally sit down and try to build
something um but you you don't learn
anything like that right you learn by
like sampling the distribution by like
interacting with yeah the thing that
you're trying to learn because like
we're very like you know humans are very
smart um but it comes from like the
interaction actions with stuff yeah yeah
yeah I know that I I was trying to Learn
Python but I didn't put the hours on
that but anyway J I mean listen I think
we have covered everything and thank you
I mean for everything I'm gonna try to
edit this I'm going to put it in Spanish
as well and and and and I'll share it
with you so you can share with the
community and I'm sure they're going to
help a lot of people as well and and you
know in the name of everyone all the
traders in that time and and myself
really thank you so much for your time
and and really thank you for for
building this tool it's it's been
amazing honestly thank you so much thank
you Freddy thank you for having me no no
no worries so speak to you soon and and
I'll see you in the chat again and thank
you thank you again yeah please let me
know all right bye all right M have a
good one thank you so much cheers